[Music]
today is a celebration of sorts it's a
culmination of all the work that we put
in this corner and a chance to apply the
lessons that we've learned and to
commemorate moments like this I think
it's important to hear from the people
who helped make that happen
so JD I want to invite you to come up
and give us a toast tell us a little bit
about what you're thinking about as you
hear these final presentations what do
you guys think I do think it would be
entertaining though to brainstorm what
might have been going through
JD's head just now when I called him I'm
thinking some vengeful thoughts about
how he was gonna get back at us or maybe
he was really impressed I mean this was
an opening that he will always remember
but if JD is anything like the rest of
us the first thing that popped into his
head was what am I going to say and as
Bert told us that thought comes with an
accompanying physiological reaction his
palms get sweaty his knees get weak arms
get heavy might have bombed it on a
sweater
Yeah right in all seriousness a lot of
us have been in the situation like this
were recalled on to give an impromptu
toast and that can be nerve-racking it
might be in class it might be at a
friend's wedding
in my case that was at my mom's birthday
party and you know in this class we've
we've gotten some lessons about how to
give impromptu speeches but it feels a
little bit different we're not talking
about what superpower you'd want to have
what you would do with an ideal day
you're being asked to capture everything
that defines what happened in a class or
over years of friendship or in a
lifetime of love and affection in just a
few seconds luckily for you guys we have
the answer on how to do that Jen and
Aaron are gonna give you six tips on how
you can deliver great impromptu speeches
and then at the end of our presentation
we're gonna call on one of you to give
an impromptu toast about this class see
now now you guys are paying attention so
with that I'll turn it over to Jen all
right all right the number one tip is
easy just keep it simple we've gone
through a variety of different public
speaking simulations in this class
including how to pitch your own startup
or how to present data in a creative way
what's different about an impromptu
toast is most people we're not planning
on hearing you speak and to be honest
most of them probably will not be
listening when you do so just remember
you're pretty much the only thing
standing between someone and that great
conversation they were already in the
middle of or that cold glass of
champagne that they really just want to
take a sip so don't stress out too much
about the toast tip number two we've
learned in the class that structure is
paramount to clarity it's how you keep
yourself from rambling indefinitely or
how you make sure that you really focus
on the message that you're trying to get
cross while there are a variety of
structures that you could try to use one
that we're proposing here is this past
present and future rule where you start
by acknowledging the past and present
and then describing the future that you
look forward to seeing this is a great
chance to incorporate some of our
learnings from JD's storytelling class
instead of just describing the past and
present capture them with an anecdote
let's say you're trying to give a toast
to someone for their birthday may not be
a collisions case where he talked about
his mom's birthday party since he
probably couldn't tell the story of
maybe when he met her as an anecdote but
another story that you let's say you're
talking about a GSB friendship you could
reflect back on that small group dinner
that the two of you first met at or
maybe that eight am accounting lecture
that you struggle to drag ourselves
through for me I gave an impromptu toast
on my last day of work and I used this
structure actually without realizing I
talked about my first day on the job and
how nervous I was to prove myself to my
teammates but when I saw the team's
tradition of decorating other co-workers
desks when they returned from sabbatical
with balloons and streamers I felt like
I joined a family I close by talking
about the future that I hope to create
one in which there was that same feeling
of family on my teams and in my
organization the last tip that I'm going
to share with you is to avoid problems
remember the point of your talk is to be
uplifting you're not there to list
everything that's wrong in your life or
at your company so let's say you're an
employee
uber if you're giving a toast at a
company party do not start by saying
well after a year marked by the forced
departure of our CEO seven
sexual harassment scandals and a lawsuit
by Google I think things are finally
starting to look up here instead even if
it's been a terrible year try to refer
to it in a neutral or ambiguous way so
instead you could lead with something
like well it's been quite a year it may
feel a little bit disingenuous to do
this but remember the point of your
toast is not to solve or dissect
problems thanks Jen the next three
lessons are focus on the people use
humor appropriately and smile relax your
audience is expecting a good story from
you with the toes of honor as a leading
character so give your audience what
they want whether that be an
embarrassing story
a funny story or a touchy story it's
easy to tell someone else's story and
let's be honest you can get away from
the five thousand spotlight that's
shining on you so which story to tell
well the first tip I can give is that
first thought that comes to mind is
often most memorable and therefore
authentic when you tell her story try to
use pronoun like you so you can't
involve your audience and not lessen the
words like I mean myself so that your
focus is back to the people humor is a
tricky ingredient it can make and break
your toast ask yourself this do you
really know your audience well so that
they for sure will laugh at your joke
way in doubt don't if your job
unfortunately fall flat quickly move on
don't let that awkwardness fill the
silence as we learn from JD even your
significant other can get lost in
translation
last relax your body and facial
expression when you are nervous and
tense your audience to feel it too and
they get dis comfortable so my personal
tip is gather as much time so you can't
before coming up here and speak so you
can't gather your thoughts and think of
something that's funny in your head so
bring a natural smile to you and for me
I think these two little guys now when
you are up here one thing to remember is
what we learn from that which is his
book speaking of without freaking out
don't think you are performing for the
audience instead reframe your mind and
think of this as having a conversation
and JD taught us health interact with
their audience such as asking a question
for example Alessandra now that you have
heard our presentation would you please
come up here and give a toast all right
well someone has to
epaulettes already mentioned this I will
have to pick someone from one of you
guys so who should I take do you not
so as we wrap up the quarter let's take
a moment and appreciate the journey that
we have been on from the benchmark
presentation where Italy showed off his
basketball skills and ended the store by
proposing to his wife to the midterm
presentations herself he showed off his
passion for pool and brought us cue and
showed us all how to use it from
impromptu exercises to forensically
waking up on Fridays not knowing where
class is gonna be that day we have come
a long way since January presumably we
all took this class because public
speaking wasn't a strong suit but we can
walk away a little bit more confident
that we have a strong foundation to give
a speech in front of a large crowd what
I am most grateful for are the strong
bonds that we formed within our cohort
we have shored share our stories
memories our passions with each other we
have built each other to be the Polish
speakers that we are today but being
present at every single exercise and
constantly giving each other feedback
but what I was going to miss the most is
Bert's contagious laughter seriously
though even if no one else in the class
laughter you joke you know you're gonna
get Birds moral support
so I like to raise my glass to the team
that went before us to my team so all
the teams are about to present as we
leave it all on the stage for our final
presentations but just know this is just
the beginning as we become leaders in
our organizations and prominence figures
in our respective spaces we're gonna
have to give speeches on almost a daily
monthly weekly basis if you're ever
brave enough to give a TED talk on a
front for a little topic like jay-z did
just know that your 3:15 family will be
here to constantly give you feedback so
you ace that presentation and most
importantly your 3:15 family will be
here to support you in any single one of
your probably speaking endeavors so
thank you
JD her and Allison for fulfilling and
engaging quarter
[Music]